people just writing in how does it make
you feel when that's what they want
well i understand it's just digital
currency now it's just a way
to feel that i've heard people say
well how am i going to let my people
know that
that i was here oh you'll just have to
tell them they'll have to believe you
unless you're a rapid liar then
of course no one's gonna believe you and
that's why you need the photo
exactly i believe that each and every
one of us has the power
within ourselves to create the life that
we
really want and i want to help give you
the tools
to make that happen i'm danica patrick
and i'm pretty intense today is a very
special
guest that people probably know much
better as citizen cope but his real name
is clarence greenwood
and we uh we got into the business of
music he is a musician he writes his own
he writes his own stuff but you'll also
understand maybe the root
of where it came from um at the
beginning of the interview where we
talked about
what his mom made him do to
get allowance to do certain things or
get away with certain things or buy
certain things
which is really foreshadowing in his
whole life of being a writer and
poet and so we talked about that we
talked about the business of music about
privacy we talk about the difficulties
of the
of the industry um we talk about
labeling i mean like how the society
just is so busy on labeling everything
but he
he doesn't really have a genre never
really has identified
or cared about what it was called that
he played whether it was pop or rock or
soul it just doesn't matter to him he's
just a pure asset heart with his music
um and we we got into spirituality he
i mean look we got into um
talking about guys like eckhart tolle
and alan watts these
amazing philosophers that have led him
down a really positive
path mentally to um to get to a better
place and to retrain his brain to think
more positively and i'm going to tell
you he does
he is he has turned really difficult
experiences into his life like his
father passing in
the abuse as a young boy into
he actually could barely even list the
bad things that came from it he really
just
had only good to say about it which is
um an
amazing transformation as a human being
so
we had a good time today he finally has
come out with
another album it's been seven years
called heroin and helicopters
uh fascinating and it starts out with a
song called duck comb feet which i
realize he's also a foodie
so um it all makes sense so please enjoy
this show with the wonderful clarence
i thought what was really um
interesting
and also probably pretty telling about
maybe the road that you were going to go
down was the story about what your mom
made you do
to get permission to do things when you
were younger
oh to read poems in order to learn or
memorize them
if i wanted to do something which was
kind of i never really
thought about that aspect of it until
retrospectively i thought about what
might have been
one of the reasons i started getting
into writing and stuff like that but
there was a robert lewis stevenson poem
called land of
counter pain and this other one uh
robert frost wrote less traveled and i
think
and i think when she started giving me
trouble about my uh
my choice of profession you know i said
well you had me
you had me memorize the real thing when
i was a kid what do you expect
well there's that one too how young were
you when you remember because the like
the road last travel is a pretty long
poem
right i think it's i think it's pretty
long but i think i wanted something
substantial like to be able to watch the
redskins on monday night or something
[Laughter]
what did you think of that were you like
this is the weirdest thing for you to
have me do
or were you or was that normal did you
just not know it she was really
into english grammar spelling
table manners things like that she went
to
catholic school so she was really into
that and and
me being a public school guy
i i really lacked a lot of
the education and i wasn't
very smart scholastically in
class or in test taking because you were
in public school
no because it was just my dna
wasn't your was it not your interest
either like it wasn't my interest but i
think
i don't think i got really into
um intellect
being intellectual until i started to
probably when i was 18 or 19 i started
to really comprehend what i was reading
because i couldn't comprehend what i was
reading when i was younger
and so it was just i could read but it
would be reading
word for word for word and it wasn't i
couldn't really
understand the the the sentence um
and i was keeping a train of thought
going of something right and underst
like
i'd read to the end of the page and i
think my mind would have gone
off yeah somewhere and then i'm thinking
what
did i just read yeah what did i read
well you're not alone that's how i
that happens to me too i'll be reading
and as soon as you get distracted you
get to the bottom of the page you're
like
hang on and then you go to the top and
it's like the first time you've read it
you're like i don't even remember
looking i don't
remember reading this right right yeah i
think your brain develops in
in different times and different people
learn in different ways and
probably one of the problems with our
school system
and education system is that we don't
allow for that
for our children to have different ways
to read
different ways to learn and
really enjoy how amazing it is to
actually
overcome something like that and
actually learn something that that
that is is good in school do you think
that we go to school
i think it's good to go to school when
we go to school do you think we do it
too early
you said that it was more like 18 or 19
before things started to really register
for you so
do you think that's the problem like we
should be climbing trees when we're a
kid
instead of absolutely i think i mean i
think there's people that really need
that
and there's there's children that can
read a book and
and really need that intellectual
stimulation
um i was more somebody who wanted to
uh run around and and and play
and and i think recess was fun and
the more the more people write about it
and right now
it's you know i think school system was
brought on so that people could work
you know their parents could work yeah
true and so therefore
almost for the parents as much as yeah
so you could go to work
and the you know the government can get
their their money
they're cut from being there parents can
go in debt to
i agree with all of this because there's
two parts of that story that resonate
with me one
was that when i was a kid i used to be
gone a lot for racing and so
there was a program in school called the
renaissance program and if you had a
certain grade point average
you could get in but the other
contingency was you had to be at a
certain amount of days of school
like you couldn't miss more than two per
per quarter or something like that
and so i was never in because i was
always gone too many days for racing but
i would always qualify with my grades
and that was when i identified as a very
young kid oh
it's because i'm not you're not making
enough money off me isn't it yeah
um and then and then of course college i
mean i
definitely i mean there's so many people
that go to college just stalling
it's culturally more acceptable to go to
college and waste your time than it is
to go travel and have life experiences
completely we've got it all wrong i
think that
there's if there's something in college
that you know you want to
really figure out and learn if you want
to learn how to be an
you know a doctor or an accountant or
something like that
and or if you really just enjoy
reading literature and want to express
writing and all these kind of things
i think but i haven't i think most
people
use it as a means to an end and i think
it's something that is
supposedly done in society so that we're
able to
um go get a good job
and so that whole thing is weird because
i think that
a lot of people finish college and
realize i've lived my whole life for
some some like society norms or
my parents goals or something else like
that so
then they become a little bit you know
that those are the type of people that
run off with a guitar to europe and just
once they decided after
you know going to some prestigious
university
but i i think that generally
i think kids go to school too early in
the morning and i've read some things
that
that basically your bones are you're
growing too much and it's not good to be
getting to school at eight o'clock
and really yeah especially when you're
an adolescent that's
why you're an adolescent you're so tired
at school
is that your bones are growing and and
you know you're
taking these classes and getting up at
6 30 or 7 o'clock in the morning when
you should be sleeping until
you naturally wake up yeah yeah i think
there's a whole lot of things wrong with
the structure of it the way it is what
would be the solution if you were
what you were in charge i think the
biggest thing is that
teachers aren't being compensated and
um i don't think that
um they're paid well enough and i think
that it would it would get more people
into
taking that as a profession and they i
think that the school systems don't have
enough money
so we've done we've really failed it at
educating
our children which i think is is you
know even when i was in school i was
like wow these schools are really not
that good
and and here i am all grown up and this
we still deal with the same problem and
you know the children are made to take
tests and to make these
get these tests done and uh standardized
tests and
and that's how they get paid accordingly
and i think
it's just an inequal inequal unequal
system
how would you what would you encourage
for
for your daughter
and i know her grandmother would kill me
especially on her mother's side actually
on both sides
i would not put her in school period no
i would just have it but there's not any
of those
i mean they say the social thing is is
important
yeah um but i think
you kind of find out what your child
wants
is is kind of capable of doing and
interested in doing
it just seems like a strange thing to
send your child off to school every day
and
and uh you don't get to see them that
much
let someone else at school raise them
and then they don't even
yeah exactly they're spending 40 hours a
week there
and with the way it is now it's
it's there's not a lot of
you know running around and uh not
enough recess no
music in the schools the art programs
are lacking
so they're kind of basically
they they want these children to learn
these to to get the standardized
test thing done so making them end a
little it's a money thing
yeah yeah it's the creativity that kills
me i just feel like when you look at a
kid they
you know they have imaginary friends
they want to climb trees they're
coloring they're making things
they you know they they're just so
imaginative and then you go into
a room with a couple of windows and all
these rules
and you know the perfect metaphor is
just like they have to
make their picture look just like
everyone else's yeah you know that's
what's accepted and
encouraged and rewarded is the um
the robotic mentality and following
rules and
you know i'm with you on that and you
said that you know when you were 18 or
19 was when you
felt like it started making sense but
that's and
and from what i understand that's when
you that's when you also realize
that you had a knack for writing and
that poem started coming out of you
really freely and it was
just after that your your great uncle
had died who
was like your father right he was a big
father figure to him he was like
a grandfather on my father's side and
i went to a small town in texas every
summer
called vernon and it was just kind of a
really small town but you know it was
i just loved going there for some reason
and
because of them and it was just he was a
farmer
he had actually had an accident when i
was real young and
lost uh his left hand in a cotton gin
and
or his right hand and and
he just he just he was just definition
of grit to me so it was just a real
inspiration and when he when he passed
away and
i started writing these poems just right
off the top of my head about the part of
therapy
or like was this something therapeutic
to you just felt like something that was
calling you because of that
incident or was it just ironic timing
like cathartic
yeah therapeutic at the same time
because i didn't
you know i had my own family situation
which at the time nobody kind of
understands and they're coming to terms
with
how they were raised and and good or bad
you know they they they go through these
periods where they're
really kind of thinking for themselves
about it and and just the reality of
what it
what that meant and that you know my
father hadn't been in my life
and uh but i had this
great man and and so i just started
writing some poems and i
never really thought that music was what
i was going to do for
what were you writing about do you
remember i think i wrote about him
i think i wrote about um
my father i think i wrote about
just coming back and forth between
like washington dc and texas you know
just some poems but i didn't stop
i just remember not just coming out like
poems are interesting because there's
different styles right there's certain
there's certain patterns and some rhyme
some have certain syllables some
right did you learn about the the
forming of a
poem or was this just your understanding
based on
what your mom had you memorized when you
were a kid yeah i think the only
thing i and which isn't even true today
which is you're supposed to have
you're supposed to start every line with
a capital letter
that was what you knew yeah and i knew
that you didn't have to nest
i mean poems had it have a situation
where you have to rhyme but
it's not like necessarily necessary that
you have to rhyme so
i think poems don't really have any laws
just like you know you have to just be
able to express an emotion that
can can reach somebody else or somebody
else can understand
something like a song but there are
parameters that go into writing song and
poetry and writing books
do you have a way to explain the
how you form how you start writing them
how they how they take shape
like do they have a chorus to them
essentially like yeah
yeah i mean i think with songwriting i
mean everyone says you know verse chorus
verse
kind of chorus bridge course um
and i've gotten in trouble for that in
the past or
been disagreed about but you know some
of the best
songs in the world don't follow that
format
you but you're just kind of entranced
by it you know whether it's bill withers
or the beatles
you know they didn't follow that formula
it but um in the sense that
you know that got to a point where that
was okay this has to be this way and
this
this has to be that way but um
i never felt i had to follow a structure
to that
and and just pretty much
how i write is is i'll just be playing
strumming on a guitar and
and and doing that
you know every day consistently then
something good happens
out of it and it's really
when you kind of mind shuts off and you
kind of let
the muse happen and it's it's a really
strange
thing that i mean you're so because
you're there
and you're in the in the moment or
whatever you're
you kind of are responsible but not
really
it's just kind of uh
i always try to people always ask me
what this song is about
and it's it's really you can go back and
read the lyrics but
a lot of times you write a song and i
was like where'd that come from um
yeah so it's almost out of body like
yeah foreign to you in some way but it
just came from somewhere and you don't
know where it came from yeah it comes
from
i guess deep into conscious somewhere i
think you know you
your mind has more power than we think
so
we're not using all our minds so when
we're in that
you know a position where you're just
kind of doing it for the love of it yeah
that it has the ability to take you
somewhere
that you never thought you could do if
you
know when you've hit on it like do you
know when you've
you've played and you've started to sing
and then all of a sudden you start going
and you're like whoa that's it
yeah i mean is it is there an enough
moment especially early on
you feel kind of there was a couple
times where i just felt a release where
i had tears of joy and it was
wow this is really good and and and
you get that sometimes or just get to
get the goosebumps or something like
that
but it's more of a kind of a spiritual
release
at that point is there anything that you
have
written and played that is is there
anything off limits do you feel like
some stuff is too vulnerable and
too true and too honest that maybe you
don't want people to see that sort of
insight or understand that insight or
maybe someone will recognize that it
might be about them like do you
do you ever is anything off limits
i think the emotion is never off limits
because emotions always going to trans
transfer to somebody be like oh that's
sad or that's happening yeah
i feel it you know this is something
that that people
even if they don't know what a song is
about people feel
something different an energy that is
is expelled or expressed
that people will will understand
but yeah there's been there's certain
personal things that i wouldn't
necessarily write about
because also just not because it's too
personal but just because of
the art of songwriting i think you're
able to be able to
use analogies and and literally
literally whatever alliterations or
whatever they're called
but kind of this is
about this but i'm going to put this in
a different context or use an analogy
for the storyline yeah yeah so really
nothing is off limits then nothing's
really off limits i mean i think you can
get
a little dark sometimes i love dark
bring it bring the dark
so i'm the kind of person that could
like work out to the dark i
i love like the deep like i love i've
always said i love depressing music
yeah is there a song that
you feel like is your most
vulnerable song has the most emotional
connection for you
well i did a whole record it was called
shotguns
and um it did never come out and it was
it was my first major record label deal
i signed with capital
and they didn't put it out and in
fairness
i don't think the record was completed
yet but
i felt the songs were really good and
it was super personal and super dark and
it was like there's a
song called shotguns and it was just
about a
i mentioned this town vernon it was
about kind of
the death of a city and also you know
the line was like
well accidents they happen with shotguns
sometimes
but this is suicide and then it kind of
dealt with suicide which
you know i'd had people in my family
deal with that
and so it was it was touched on that and
then
i had a song about officer friendly
about a guy killing his brother so it
was like a
it was like a cane and able kind of
themed to the whole to the whole story
how'd that make you feel that what you
can even reflect on now
as being your most vulnerable album not
getting not being released
i was tough i mean i felt like
because i'd come from you know just when
i was buying and selling tickets to
concert and i
made all these decks instead selling
tickets to nascar races
nascar races so i thought i'd
kind of made it and when you sign a
major deal back yeah you're like okay
my songs are as good as this person i'm
yeah i'm going straight to the top
did you have confidence is that not a
problem for you
no i it was definitely a problem i had
i had confidence in writing songs right
but i had which
i've had to work a really bad stage
fright so like performing was really
hard
and it wasn't like i was going to be a
pro
i never thought i'd be a performer i
just thought i'd be a songwriter a
producer
so then the album doesn't get published
and it's a vulnerable album which is
like a double hit almost right because
yeah it was a pr
it was something it's not like i you
know somebody else wrote the song so
i remember getting the call like it was
yesterday you know
clarence we got to let you go yeah i'm
like
i don't know what that means where am i
going
and so i just
i just figured i had enough money to you
know in the
time me and my i mean my girlfriend at
the time split up
and she was like well if you're not
gonna
if you don't make it you're gonna be
miserable and if you do
you won't ever be around so i was
was she right she was probably right
um it was probably one of the best
things for her that
somebody's done for me but
it was i've been with her for a long
time so it was like
you know she was kind of my high school
sweetheart and um but she
it was it was kind of a very unselfish
thing of her to do so
it then i i got this place
uh kind of a big
um big room like a
a carriage house and it was it was like
2500 square feet
and i never lived in somewhere where i
could really sing out and
i was always kind of quiet and and
felt weird about the neighbors and all
that kind of stuff and
it was i think it was like eight hundred
dollars but it was it was
kind of in a prostitute and drug
area in dc at the time probably enjoyed
yours enjoyed your music then so there
was a lot of
it was a lot of good you know it was
but there was never any any problems
there but it was always
i could just sing out and so i just
started writing a whole new record
because under that record deal i wasn't
allowed to
to redo any of those songs for five
really
so then so you wrote them sorry and then
they still owned them even though they
got rid of you i wrote them i recorded
on them
they own the rights to to the
to the what i'd recorded and basically
that i couldn't record them again for
another five years that's [ __ ]
that's the music business tell me about
it what's the most difficult thing about
the music business
uh or maybe list them list all of the
things
well first i'll say there are a lot of
really good people
in the music business but the structure
of it's built
more as a corporate um thing where it's
done for every quarter
so an art i think it it
minimizes the ability to have
really good art and to continue really
good artists because
they're they're they have to meet their
bottom line so
and once they became corporate that's
what happened and so
so it's it's been a lot of kind of
innocuous music being put out
and not testing the boundaries and that
said there's been
really good people in the music that
have helped
me and you know that system has helped
me a lot
and was able to make records
on other people's uh dime and
get a little money in my pocket and
but it is a cons i think the money is a
good thing but also can be a challenging
thing because
people don't you know people sign 50
groups and you're just one of them so
it's it's not you know and maybe two out
of or maybe five out of that 50 will get
the record put out
and then maybe one out of those 50 will
have a career
is it a crapshoot or
is there an element where if you do
certain things you know you have a
better chance of
being chosen to be
released recorded toured yeah
i think i i think in
some sit a lot of situations the cream
rises to the top
yeah but you can have really talented
people that just took the wrong turn
you know they signed with the wrong
person or
they they didn't believe in themselves
and then they
had other people write they got the
wrong producer and that could happen
you know so it really has to come with
if it's really about the art and about
the music and about your songs
then you're not going to really let
anything stand in the way of you
getting the music to the people because
at the end of the day
you can play places and you don't need
them to do that you can try to build
your own
fan base you can get your music to
people somehow and
that's really what you have to make
yourself label proof
if you're on a label so what's the point
of a label then what do they what do
they have to offer that's so great
they have for one most
most artists don't have the money to
make a record and then
have the money to
[Music]
spend the time and developing it and
then also
touring and marketing and radio are all
expenses
and i really didn't get on the radio but
that's a big expense you know for you
know like especially pop artists so the
record label pays
the radio station they don't pay him to
say hey play it but it costs a lot of
money to actually
to service those stations and and what
does that mean
service the station i mean go ahead be
vulgar i don't know what this means
podcast we can swear we can say whatever
we want well they don't
i mean if there was a station that
actually took money
i would i would bring back with it me
and
so what's service mean then um
it's you have to go there
and you're you're promo person takes
them out
and if they they they don't they're not
allowed to
to to be paid directly anymore right so
you have to hire
independents got it and an independent
will
you know figure something out and and
radio people
get i mean it's r it's
it's really hard to understand whether
the song
the hit song makes itself or if the
radio station makes it because they
don't play
other stuff they all play the same stuff
that's right so
but the actual to do the promotion
of uh a pop record
is is millions of dollars yeah so i
never was on that
in that light but are you glad
i would have liked to pop would you have
compromised your
your art to some degree no in that
position
i didn't think i had to i mean i think
there was a point when i was on a major
and
you know they said they're going to want
their commercial single and i felt like
i delivered that when i delivered the
record they
they thought that that was the case so
when i put out the clarence greenwood
recordings i was on arista which was a
big
major kind of situation and they were
ready to push the button and
then the whole staff got fired and it
was just
it was it was awful so i had to
fell apart on you it fell apart and that
had dick that went
to so i got kind of adopted by another
label and did that label dissolve on
some level then just because everybody
or did so much change
it is not part of that anymore it was
dissolved it was kind of everyone got
fired and they didn't get rehired so
they caught
for some reason they shut the label down
because it was a big
pop label was spending a lot of money it
was like whitney houston and
oh wow santana was honest it was a lot
of pop groups so they all kind of got
all the artists got dispersed within
other labels in the sony system at the
time
and um but you know you have your
champions so your champions believe in
you and they understand your vision and
they understand the music you're making
and a lot of times they say oh wow this
isn't
traditional pop music but i can take
this here
and i know what to do you know jimmy
iveen was always good at that
and la reid different executives and
stuff
well you don't have an identifiable
genre
is that correct yeah that's always been
kind of the difficult thing
is but you know with a good song you can
change that genre to get closer to you
and i think by changing the music just a
little bit no instruments or the sound
or just
the right person bringing it to the
right person getting getting
you know getting them to believe in it
enough to
to press the button essentially you know
there's not going to be very many people
that they're gonna
wanna they can afford to or they wanna
press the button and if something
they have this term in the music
business they say they throw to
throw the thing on the gum on the wall
see if it sticks
you know so it's just kind of a
sometimes just magical things happen and
then sometimes it really takes
a lot i mean it takes a lot to break a
record
so i mean what i did with that record
was i convinced them to
press a bunch of copies of the app the
full album before it came out and i was
giving it away to people and people
liked it i would come back and give them
more
and they would give stuff away so i
think that was like one of the best
marketing things i could have done
i feel like this i feel like culturally
we have an obsession with um
labeling everything yeah you know
everything needs to
be identifiable and understood and
instead of experiencing things we need
to
have a label whether it's democrat or
republican or
pop or you know rock
you know back to a redskins fan or a
packers fan like you
you know you you need a label for
everything you identify with one of
26 and probably growing identifiable
genders now i mean yeah
our race our gender our right culture is
all
is all kind of put into our our
what we feel like we need to protect
or or to promote and
and all that really doesn't matter on
your dying bed
you know so it's i guess it's important
to figure that out before
you're there
well or not we can evolve as people we
don't always have to be the same person
we don't have to believe in the same
thing today
and next year no i know i'm just saying
this figure
to figure out that it's not important
like all those things that we think that
we hold on to
yeah as far as far as our identity and
that we don't necessarily um
sometimes are kind of operating on a
lower
frequency because right we're all part
of the same thing well i was part of the
same universe right
what um i know that something that kind
of is
not in your comfort zone you mentioned
you don't like being on stage
have you gotten over that by the way
yeah i've gotten over i still get a
little nervous but i
i you know i used to have just
it was it was hard it was hard and they
call it stage fight for a reason
yeah but but the public and like being
recognized and
you know the public's obsession like
this addicted society to
um you know people or things
stuff um you know this obsession with
fame
and it's you know
has that been challenging for you well i
think
the strangest thing to me is the cameras
and the tv
and people always want to take pictures
and
and and i think that that is
is one of the things since the cell
phone
came up that that that's completely like
taylor swift had it right she said
selfies of the new autograph yeah she's
right well she that was a long time ago
she said that but yeah i mean people
don't
it's almost like a drug you see them
pulling their phone out and they come
and and they don't have really any
any interest in and having any kind of
uh
true meaningful conversation or or
anything like that i agree it's just
it's just the picture it's not there's
not a
any kind of exchange which i think is
experience yeah we're
we're missing out on on you know how did
you hear the music or how did you
and then or she says or he says
this you know a lot of times you do get
people that have a personal story about
it
but it always comes with a picture
you know i've been when my daughter was
younger i stepped out of a cab one time
and
this guy's like i take a picture of you
and i'm like
i'm with my daughter and i had her and i
was just like
she can be in it too like i don't think
you're understanding me sir
but but i've literally had people write
in and you know when i
because i stopped taking pictures for a
long time and now i just
i can't win that fight anymore so it's
like all right i'll take a picture
but um people just writing in
how does it make you feel when that's
what they want
well i understand it's just digital
currency now it's
just a way to feel that
i've heard people say well how am i
going to let my people know
that that i was here oh you'll just have
to tell them they'll have to believe you
unless you're a rapid liar then
of course no one's going to believe you
and that's why you need the photo
exactly yeah that connection i agree
um you know people will want an
autograph or
want a picture or something and i
remember a long time ago saying
don't you just want to like say hi good
luck and have a
have a couple words with me isn't that
more memorable right
than no interaction at all and just an
autograph you can buy online
yeah like why wouldn't you want to just
say something to me
well it takes longer for somebody to
figure out the camera and then do the
whole thing and then
then it would and then you get the
picture and then there
like you say there's no interaction with
them so if you had to choose between
a two to three minute conversation with
a fan versus
a photo i would have the conversation
yeah i think that i i don't have
i enjoy that you know i'll give you a
hug and hello and where was my hug when
i came in then
you were carrying a guitar and that's
why but
that there is that you know
there's that and so many people have it
it's wild that
the level of it like people that are on
television
it's just it's crazy yeah you know
because they
they have to always be on or or a lot of
athletes and stuff like that
where it's it's when you guys
have it all the time where people did
see me normally know my music
or been to a show and so it's it's got
there's like there's a level of
authenticity to it
but i still would like to go out at the
end of the night and just be like what's
up
relax in public spaces and just say
hello to people and just have
conversations and not necessarily be
about
the pictures you know yeah the
superficial part of it
yeah the fleeting part the
non-connective right i mean
look you're you're a poet so you connect
with words and you connect with emotions
yeah and when someone snaps a picture
that's that's the opposite you know
there's no connection there
and i don't think i got it i mean i
definitely wanted to make my life better
and all that and
prove people that didn't think i was
going to do something
you know there were those like kind of
lower level
you know introduction reasons that i got
into things
but um i think
i always saw that fame is so fleeting
it's like no matter how famous you are
the next person is
that's gonna you know i remember when i
was a kid they had a show called the
partridge family
yeah and they were all like superstars
and yeah it was like there was only five
channels and
it's like you know there's
there's new there's new stuff and
it's a matter of what's next right you
have to do one more thing that's
one more thing that's crazy or more
revealing or
more controversial and you know you
that's what you have to do to just
stay on the radar so that you can
get casted in a movie or have your album
come out or be number one with the label
or or whatever it may be that's in your
profession that you
feel like you need so what would you
what would you what would you have as
advice for someone that was getting into
the music industry based on what you've
learned
i wouldn't really no i'm joking
uh i would i would just say you have to
really love it more than you love
the the the rewards you're gonna think
you're gonna get
because those rewards aren't gonna
really be fulfilling to you
so that what's most fulfilling is is
when you can
break through on a song or make
something that you thought you never
could do or
kind of go outside of
what you thought you could do as a human
and then that those are the rewards the
rewards
aren't the money and the fame and all
that stuff those are really
really kind of baseline things
that that happen well they happen as a
result of doing something you're
passionate about right because that
resonates like you said
people resonate with that frequency and
that energy of a song having meaning and
depth yeah and it i agree 100
agree and so so much of society
and i'm i've been guilty of it you know
you're looking for
validation or something outside of you
to
make you feel better when what you have
to do is you have to find that within
yourself because if you're looking
outside of yourself to feel good
it's either going to be temporary or
just not happen it's for sure going to
be
disappointing beyond beyond what happens
when you disappoint yourself
so looking within to figure out how to
be happy is
of course i i love that self-growth i
think that's one of the things that is
lost in
you know i mean it's not that it's
completely lost but i feel like in my
exposure with
religions let's say it's always about
going outside of yourself
ask for for the forgiveness go do this
go do something instead of going
what about you what are you thinking
about how do you feel like
more self reflection and
self-improvement
did you grow up going to church or like
yeah not a weekly thing but my
grandmother on my mother's side was
devout catholic and then in texas they
were pretty
heavy uh presbyterians so
it was but it my mother
got a divorce so she wasn't really into
the church she would go but
every once in a while but um
so i was i was christened as an
episcopalian
so i never really went too many days in
church
but the whole like in texas there was
like 50 churches
and all this in town yeah and
then you know all of them had different
ideas and and
um so so i i
i remember seeing something or reading
something where there's like
the guy said there's a lot of church
with they don't know if there's a lot of
god in the church
you know and so i never felt the
religious
dichotomy i felt there was a spiritual
something higher i believed in something
higher and i believed that there was
uh and i didn't know what it was i
couldn't say that that's
jesus or that's allah that's technically
nobody knows
yeah so i think that um
and i and i really commend people who
feel like that that they know that and
that it's helped them
to another level but i just know that
um it's helped me
as far as knowing that there's something
more powerful on earth than
just all the all the stuff that's going
on good or bad
does that um how does that how does that
affect your life i mean
so you describe yourself as spiritual
then yeah
yeah um
i think just knowing kind of wanting to
treat people the way you want to be
treated and
it's the golden rule it's all it's all
i think all religions have a lot of the
same basic premises
and so that that a lot of those things
are are important to live by
um and i do believe that
but the laws is something that i i feel
are a little strange well this person is
not allowed to go to the
dance or this person's not allowed to
drink liquor or this person's you know i
think
when when you have or he's not allowed
to listen to this type of music
when you have those things it just
pushes people toward those things
i think that's why you have so much you
know
sin in the church and you have so much
uh
you know there's you know between men
and women
it's kind of messed up
are what what men and women
really have in a relationship
and i think it's because it's it's been
it's been told that this is what you're
supposed to do as a man and this is what
you're supposed to do as a woman and
sex is supposed to be this way and it's
supposed to be for this it's not
supposed to be enjoyed and it's
whatever you feel you're not really
you're kind of guilted into thinking
okay well
i can't do this and or i'm going to go
to hell yeah and if i don't
um get married before i do this and i
think it just brings on this
you know i think alan watts the
philosopher said something about how it
felt like christianity
and judaism was one of the things that
made
men in in the west so obsessed with sex
because it's it and because it was not
allowed yeah
some level love alan watts he's great to
listen to you
he's uh he has such a um
uh powerful simple voice i listened
about 45 minutes on alan watts about
i mean i've listened to many many many
of uh his um his bits and
recordings but um he's uh he is a really
fascinating philosopher and he puts very
complex
thoughts in a simple way yeah um
it was a the most recent one was about
about 50 minutes and it was about
realizing like the journey to yourself
and
um and what the self is and he's just
i'd love to hear him laugh
in his videos too and he'll just start
talking and all of a sudden he'll just
laugh
at his own um conclusions that are so
simple and he's like don't you all get
it
yeah he doesn't say that but it feels
like that like it's this simple people
um but how did you like how did you
arrive at i mean i've you know
i've read that you said that all of your
music
is about consciousness yeah explain
how explain that to what does that mean
to you
well i think it's just it you know
even if i write about a character that's
not me or something i feel
that i've lived that lived a lot of
people
like i'm part of that person so if
there's a flawed individual
in that a lot of the stuff that
that i might write is is not saying okay
this is a bad situation or that's a bad
situation because i've
i've done that myself and and
i have a song called bullet and a target
and
never heard of it what do you mean you
know it's just
but it can be looked at as society doing
all this
and and religion and
and and the government and all this
but it can also be you know you point
your finger at yourself as well
and and so i think that
a little bit along the lines of we're
all one kind of a yeah
i think that for a long time
i lived in the life and us and i'm still
struggling with it
of the past and the in the future
and and so okay this
there was a point where i was motivated
to do things in my life because of my
past
and what i wanted in the future and i
didn't really
realize the importance of of
being kind of president in the moment
and i think
when i started writing songs i didn't
know this but that's where it was taking
me it was taking me to some place where
all that stuff didn't matter and um
even performing was hard to get in that
so i was like
you know i don't i don't have a i mean i
do feel that
there's part of the world and and and
our life and
and that is not at all
you know nice and there are
because of what we've been born into
there's people that do really bad things
sure and
groups that we were talking about labels
and
and all this kind of this when people
are labeled into one kind of group or
us americans or the russians or the
communists or the capitalists
we have the tendency to even it can be
in a group
kind of like mob mentality
where we can even do worse things to
each other
and religions have gone and you know
catholicism has been responsible for
many people dying
that's right and so
i do think there's an aspect of
of us all being part of the
you know universe not just people but
the rocks and the mountains and all that
other stuff the heirs
because we're part of it and what woke
you up to that
was there a moment or something that
happened where
things just started to make sense
i was just i started doing some
meditation but
i think before that
i always realized you know it wasn't
good to steal
i could steal something if i wanted to i
could walk into the store and steal it
and i was like
um i
felt that there was just certain things
that you could do that you don't have to
necessarily make somebody else a victim
of what
of you getting in the way you know
somebody else is in the way
is a better way to you can still
succeed or do what you have to do
without somebody else being
is that something that you were thinking
or was that like an emotional feeling
could you feel
did you feel empathy was that were you
feeling yeah i think god
i think all artists i think all artists
have or
at least me has a pretty
big sense of empathy but i think that's
pretty much
because um
and and that's a bad thing you know you
can be empathetic and then that's why
when you feel people's vibes or feel the
suffering or the pulse in the world that
you know yeah it leads you to all these
other things like possibly
um having substance abuse problems or
all these other things that
they can go along with that when you're
an artist
and um i think
most people that even that aren't
artists that are empathetic
kind of struggle with that and because
because because this world will there
will be people that will
definitely take advantage and you don't
think as a person that
because you wouldn't do it they'll
they'll they'll think they won't
yeah and that took me a long time to
realize
did you have to learn that the hard way
absolutely
because i oh no i wouldn't do that
was this people that were part of people
you loved or was there strangers that
would do this
well you know i don't i don't
i don't want to put myself i was never
victimized by anything i put myself in
all these positions
so i knew that like there are risks
to doing things that you want to do
yeah and there are going to be people
that
want what you have if somebody robs you
you know or takes your money or
whatever it is comes in your house or
puts a gun to your head it's like
it's you know you're not necessarily
you know there's things that you that
you can learn from that
so it's not necessarily being a victim
of it
right even the things that happen with
my record company and all that kind of
stuff in the
over the years i don't i always felt
like
i i you know there was a long time i was
like man this
this person this [ __ ] this guy like
this guy
but um i learned from it
yeah so there there was there was life
lessons that go along with that yeah
yeah
speaking of you know kind of
self-reflection
dealing with things is um
in the seven years that it was between
you writing
your most recent album this year in 2019
was 2012 and in the
in the middle of that your your dad died
is that right yeah
and obviously you know
i don't know how much you're willing to
go into but he was he was not around and
yeah i was estranged from my father and
uh
he kind of was part of my life when i
was younger but
i don't remember my parents being
together so i used to go down to texas
and stay
with his side of the family and um
oh that was something you had to face
right you
because you yeah it was it was just you
know i talked to him before he passed
away we actually kind of
came to some terms and i wish i kind of
wish my sisters had done the same thing
um but uh
because i saw him not as
as someone like somebody i had to fear
but just kind of as a flawed individual
and a flawed weak individual and i
didn't
that kind of gave me the power to feel
you know not to have hatred in my heart
about it because for a while that was
there was some really strange emotions
going on about it
not just about not being around him
but um or
the things that go along with that you
know not
you know getting a call on your birthday
or just just people disappearing and not
even calling you for years and then
but you know there was there was there
was some physical stuff that went on so
it was like
you know that i dealt with with him
and i was probably pretty too young to
how were you like eight nine years old
you know but i think when he left i was
in the fifth grade but you know he was
some
pretty deep deep things and then i
realized that
his father had done the same thing to
him and so
and that was just the way you know but
you know not just programming yeah and
you're not you're not really
you don't understand when because
sometimes that happens and
and then because pretty much everyone
and that
you know growing up in my day i had to
deal with that
but really well a lot of people did i'm
sure
i mean a lot of people got um beat and
stuff so
you think that was different for girls
or boys or do you think that was an
era i think it was probably different
from girls but
i hope it was i think
that was probably a rite of passage for
a boy to get
beat by the father or something you know
it was probably like somewhat of a badge
of honor
what did you what did it do to you
i think it made me
like i was saying it just had fear of
certain things
i think and i was operating like that
someone was going to beat you up
or fear of someone disappointing you or
what does that mean when you say you
were scared of him or you gave you fear
well i was scared of my father for a
while because of that
i don't you know and what was weird
about when i saw him i was like okay
he's just this guy that's kind of like
awkward and and you know he's showing me
some papers and
a check that he gotten you know i just
got
you you see them in such higher
higher levels when you're younger and
then and then
to realize that they're just human and
and that
nobody in their right mind would would
you know
be the child with a metal hanger you
know like that's just not
something that you you would think
somebody would do
but that happens and it happens a lot if
you were to
take a positive and a negative from that
experience
what would it be i think the positive is
that i i would never touch my children
and it took me a while to even have
children
because i think that um physically
um and
another positive it drove me to be a
great songwriter
and i think that it gave me experience
and
uh it
it kind of toughened me up a lot and i
think um and i think
at the same time it probably made me a
lot
kind of not
tough you know because realizing that
your father would do that to you
yeah and uh
just that and just
you know it's not i think the i think
there's more positives to it the
negatives i think
you have a great ability to be able to
spin things in a really positive way
have you always been positive or is that
no i think i lived uh
i i feel like i lived out of fear in a
lot of ways because i even just
okay what what motivated me
was was out of fear and realizing that
that's not what i want to be
motivated by anymore and
and so um
and realizing he wasn't neces
that wasn't directed toward me that was
his own thing and i think
a lot of times people you know
you know i have friends whose parents or
family members are heavily have drug
problems and stuff like that and it's
like their own battle
and it's affected them deeply but it's
it's
it it was something that that
if you continue to to concentrate on
that negative aspect it'll take you
if you use it as a as a motivation it'll
take you to a certain point
but it can't take you up there it's like
that that
i said there's no way you can go
really really you know up there that's
intuitive potentially infinite
as opposed to a threshold right and
there is a
there is a ceiling that that can take
you to and if you want to be at that
ceiling
and knock your head against it all the
time then then and use that as
how did you learn that did you go to
therapy did you have a good friend that
helped you with that
i mean these are deep concepts that are
difficult to understand unless you
sought them out through someone from
someone
read something watched something on tv
read you know watch some video or listen
to a podcast which you definitely
think it wasn't happening 20 years ago
30 years ago but but that's how i
learn now like that i learned from my
friends from listening to things
watching things
reading and you know those are deep
that's
self-actualization is difficult yeah
well
i don't think you i think that's been
everything you know all those things
that have come together as far as
trying to seek out some type of
philosophy or this kind of
uh readings and this you did mention
alan watts
yeah and and how did you hear ellen
watts
i got turned on to him i was watching
some other
some other podcasts and stuff i i love
eckhart tolle
oh yeah he's the other one that has the
giggle
yeah both of those guys have the giggle
they do they'll say something
and especially eckhart it'll just be
like this and then
he'll like he'll explain something so
simply and he'll like land on like a
conclusion or something and he'll just
giggle it's the same thing as ellen
watch
and sometimes he pisses me off because
he's like when he giggles he's like you
know if you want to live your life like
that hey
that's right yeah that's how i've been
living my life
you're like don't laugh at me don't
belittle me
yeah so you listen to some of that stuff
listen and read
and and and before that there would just
be little
kind of books and stuff like that that
you would
kind of come across and yeah i remember
oprah winfrey
was like turned beyond i think she
turned me onto eckhart totally too and i
don't
really from her super soul stuff for
sure no it was before
oh from her show show yeah but i think
that
it's weird because i don't i didn't
watch oprah very much
and i didn't really watch tv shows very
much but for some reason it was like
there was a couple things she had on her
show and okay let me check this out
it was supposed to be do you believe in
like frequency and energy
definitely i mean we've already touched
on it but
like the fact that possibly
you were raising your frequency or your
vibration
and it sort of met that met that
frequency
of echartoleon oprah right like at that
level
you were feeling that kind of energy and
so
you know the like attracts like kind of
theory
yeah do you believe in that absolutely i
think there was a time
recently i i went to this meditation
thing kind of
i kind of called like meditation for
dummies and because i know
everyone feels dumb meditating you're
not alone everyone's like am i doing it
right
i never understood it and this guy was
was was explaining the um
that what the mind does and i wouldn't
like
in meditation yeah or what it does and
what what the mind is
basically taught teaches us to
the in in totally talks about the same
thing alan watts like it's
ancient wisdom and i think we've been
excuse me we've been fooled to to
to not understand what this ancient
wisdom really was and
kind of lost sight of that yeah and that
our mind is
is can somewhat be our enemy
and and i mean that's not what they say
but
i kind of like it's like wow that sounds
like the devil it works in the game of
polarity
it's your it's your ally and your enemy
right it's not nothing it's something
and it can be
over here too it can be very helpful but
it can be absolutely debilitating which
is your heaven and hell on earth you
know
yeah and completely
and he and he he just kind of did
it did these meditation practices and i
was
doing them with somebody from class are
you still doing i was like yeah
and i was like wow how how
i was like i just felt like i really
needed it because my mind was
just racing and it was the all this
stuff that goes on in
in the world yeah and in your life
so are you a regular meditator now yeah
but i'm more
i i started out with the whole uh
guided meditation thing which is which
is
you know and i stopped using that
that person it was this guy joe dispenza
he did just talked to joe two weeks ago
a week or two ago yeah he's
fascinating yeah and he really explains
what your mind is doing
yeah it's it's it kind of when you
realize that that's what you've been
doing then
then it's kind of like a what are you
going to do about it
well you're going to keep repeating the
same story yeah which of course he says
you know
over time it's 50 percent of it at least
isn't even real anymore maybe even gets
the point
nearly the whole story isn't real
anymore but
you have to reprogram your mind to
create a new reality and you to create a
new personal reality you're gonna need a
new personality and you're gonna have to
think different
completely uh i was uh how long ago was
that
that was a couple years ago i did this
thing for like four days
one of his retreats yeah he says he only
does seven days now i'm like all right
i'll go
he's like you're supposed to do this
online course first for like nine weeks
i'm like
can i skip that and he's like maybe well
i had the thing it was like i think
i did the online thing but it wasn't
that it wasn't nine weeks okay it was uh
maybe i was supposed to do it over nine
weeks but maybe it was nine episodes or
five episodes yeah
went there was it worth it was it worth
doing that i mean is it i mean because
look i think it was
completely worth it because then it kind
of gave me an idea of what
meditation
that's why i call it meditation for
dummies i didn't really know
right what it was i understood oh you
have to say a breath or a mantra
or all these different things but i
didn't he kind of explained what
what the mind was doing and um
and then i was at first i started
kind of dozing off during meditations
yeah and then kind of rose to where it
wasn't
that and then having feelings of
euphoria
which i've never felt before which are
kind of
and they say it's different for
everybody so people see
visions and
it definitely was a was a cool
how did that did would you say it
changed your life
i mean i think it was one of the things
but i think
it i think there's been so many things
that have changed my life but i think it
definitely improved
my quality of life yeah what do you do
different now because of it
well or how do you i think it's evolved
into something where i can
somehow get into the state of meditation
without meditating
and and also performing
and not you know a lot of stuff to watch
and totally talk about too is just
basically
um
not losing my cool and this business is
so hard to
not lose your cool and your ego gets
involved in it
so it's it's and i still do lose my cool
but
there's i'm starting to learn how to
be aware that that's happening and
you know somebody just steal right in
front of you know take
you know i'm not paying you type thing
and then
you know we're taught oh you have to
defend yourself
and all this kind of stuff you know so
right i think that's helped
um probably just my relationships
have been an improvement my way
more patient with those too yeah because
uh you know the
once you realize that ego is basing a
lot of
you're basing a lot of stuff on ego yeah
and past
experiences yep yeah and what you can
have in the future
then you don't
you're not leaving yourself enough time
and
and and physically i've felt a lot of
those
bad energies leave my body in meditation
so really yeah like do they want to come
back on some level did you feel like an
energy
shift at some times going back that way
kind of like well you have moment but
it just almost like
i it was i don't know how to explain it
but as i almost a massage
for the spirit was coming out and
releasing this stuff and i don't know
it wasn't bad it felt good so i don't
know it was just i guess there was
i think when you you are in that
position where you do rely
so much on your past and future
then if you're the most
kind of unconscious person then that's
how you kind of reach
some kind of consciousness and
and you know luckily i wasn't somebody
that tried to
put ill will toward people or you know i
never felt that
need yeah um but i feel like for me
with energy is like i haven't never felt
anything quite like that before where
you there's
a body euphoria i can get that through
certain kind of breathing techniques and
things like that where
it's like a full body tingle like yeah
euphoria something else like your whole
body feels so amazing i can get that
from from breathing
but for me with energy what it was is
that as
i was improving my life and my
thoughts yeah and the way i reacted to
people
and it i felt like it was a rise in
frequency
and that the things that were below that
no longer
certain people or certain certain
activities or things like that
they didn't resonate with me anymore i
couldn't i wasn't even interested in
them anymore they didn't
they weren't interesting to me they
seemed like a waste of time
um so for me it was more about like
these things didn't they fell away
of importance and i i just
i didn't even want to let i didn't even
feel good
entertaining certain thoughts or certain
people or certain things they just
didn't
i had to get away from them because they
didn't feel good actually
did you ever did you yeah that's a
freeing moment yeah and then that's
that does make you feel a lot better
yeah one of the things that
was interesting about one of the totally
things he was talking about
he was saying how you have to how
people don't spend a lot of time in the
moment
and that he actually did a reference to
a race car driving
and he said that i was wondering why
your hand was up on the wheel
you don't have to be you know jumping on
or
climbing some cliff that's gonna you
know it's a lot of people that
that the only way they can get to that
moment is like some life
harrowing experience i was gonna ask you
what what did you think about when you
were driving
um i mean i didn't feel like i was gonna
die
i mean it was more of like it probably
i've actually it's been said to me that
it's
probably was like i enjoy moving
meditation
so for me it might be like a walk or
that i almost feel like i get into like
a
like a mental trance of something or
very connected feelings of sensitivity
whether it's like gratefulness or
beauty um they've come the veil is so
thin then so i can be on a walk with my
dogs and just kind of start crying
because i just feel like
it's so freaking beautiful the dogs are
so happy i'm so happy
life is so good but that doesn't happen
in my waking life walking around i'm not
like oh wow i'm driving a really nice
car to this big mansion and going to
dinner with these certain people i don't
just go i'm so
happy it takes sort of like a certain
atmosphere
um for that for me but i would say that
it's been described that that's probably
was my moving meditation right
and that makes sense because that's what
i relate to now
but i would feel very um i felt alone
that's how amanda didn't feel like
anyone else was around or anything else
was going on i didn't ever feel like
anyone was looking at me
yeah which is why i threw things and
kicked things because i just
i really like was in my own world and so
you're very much responding on
it's very reflexive like you that's why
experience pays off at that job is
because
you based on all your past experiences
can help lead you to a better decision
on track
because you don't have time to think
like life so it's almost very out of
body
yeah did did you i'm so you wouldn't be
like oh man i didn't
i didn't uh feed the dogs today
oh um probably not your mind like ever
it's just always actually the one thing
that would happen to me on track that i
would be like
why is this happening or like why that
why is it that one
is i would sometimes get a song in my
head oh really
oh wow and i would just be singing it
out there and i'd be going down the
straightaway
singing the words going that is the
dumbest song why am i singing it
like i can remember one time i sing like
a it was a
like a miley cyrus song or something
like that
why that one why not let the drummer
kick
like i said that was on aaron's playlist
all right
for like pre-game pre-game playlist so
i probably wasn't listening to the right
music but um i heard about that story
yeah but i didn't i didn't believe it
how long ago did you hear about that
story
this was a lot it must have been 10 15
years yeah he said
that's what he's like he's like oh oh my
god you're gonna you're gonna talk to
him he's like
but the drummer kick was on my playlist
on my pregame playlist for
so long he was so excited somebody said
did you know that aaron rodgers
your music is on there and i was like
yeah that would be cool i didn't know if
it was true and you just
sorry you just verified it yeah true
story
you your music resonates with people and
i think that you know
you are an incredible storyteller i was
listening to
um the new album and i was listening to
even
kind of thinking of the songs that i
wanted you to to play today
and i was like maybe you should play
duck confit
[Laughter]
because it's like at the end you're like
oh and it's just i love the storytelling
it's really wonderful um before we
get into that i just kind of want to
talk about your your daughter um
and how you know maybe that's i mean
like how has that changed i don't have
kids but
people ask me all the time but and
so how so you were 40 40 ish
when you had her or 42. yeah
and i made and i'm creeping up on that
yeah she
she just i guess i never felt that
love before so even though i've been
had plenty of love in my life but having
that amount of or being ex
the way somebody says you know daddy or
something like that it's just
like oh my god it's just it's and it's
just
i always say having a child is the most
selfish thing you can do
so why would you say that
i guess because i mean they look like
you
and then you get to get all this love
and
you know and then they're uh
they're just
i think that it's it's it's kind of a
new
experience and that people always say oh
it changes your life and i don't
really feel like it changes your life i
think it just
changes your circumstances but also
allows you to
allows you to really benefit highly off
of somebody else's
presence and and but i always felt like
i wasn't going to do it
well what made you finally decide to do
it i don't know i just got
pushed into it i guess con convinced
is it true then you're never you're
never truly ready
you're definitely never ready you know
what's the first time they have like you
think you're you're ready for anything
and then they start
your fever gets up to 100 something and
you're like oh my god
[Laughter]
i have two dogs and my life is about
trying to keep them alive
and i thought i think i saw a cute
coffee cup that said something like task
today keep children alive
like that would i don't know i feel like
you know obviously with dogs they're
dogs and they
have you know primal instincts to
survive but kids need
everything especially
especially in the you know especially
guidance and understanding and the thing
is they're not
they're not going to be you and they're
going to have different
goals and they're going to have
different experiences and they're going
to
be raised a different way so
how they are in their spirit and their
soul is it's kind of
some people believe children choose
their parents you know i think that's
pretty
out there but you know that could be
true and then there's
there's for their own growth and
development
and then i just haven't um
she's just amazing she just makes me
makes you happy and she makes you sad
when she says something
to use daddy you've been gone for two
two months she's probably going to
school these days too so you're like
yeah that's cool sad things
yeah you just seeing seeing how
how society can mold them it's not just
you
is that scary yeah just
and then things that they're struggling
with and
things that they really seeing joy
seeing them experience something for the
first time yeah
what has she taught you about yourself
uh she's come along well
she taught me i could be a good father
that's beautiful i didn't think
i was like her mother says you're a
natural at this and i was like
uh you should have you know you should
have more oh
okay okay that's probably the best case
scenario then for having
having a having a child is
to maybe not be convinced but then be
like maybe you should have more
yeah i mean at least i'm good up to this
point i don't
you know i haven't messed up
was that part of
why you didn't write an album for seven
years
yeah i was pretty much we moved
from new york and i was just spending
time with her
and then me and her mother were going
through some difficult times
personally and then i didn't really feel
that inspired i was always writing and
stuff but
and then i'd be on the road and do some
shows and then
it just it just kept on going and it
wasn't it seems like a lot of time but
it didn't seem like that long to me but
it was did you have a lot of content
then when you came around to write this
album
or had a lot of record a lot of songs um
they weren't you know because i was
struggling in my relationship i don't
feel like they were going
in the right on the right frequency
is back to frequency yeah makes sense
and uh but and also not being
kind of i always kind of want to be in
one place and
be comfortable in that place and
i was just kind of moving around from
hotels and airbnbs and then
be on the road and that kind of thing
like that so did you have a house
actually to live in or were you just
really moving i was moving around
like dave moved out here and i was in
new york and then i was just like i
gotta go
out there to be with her so i just moved
out here and
i was kind of doing that and i always
used to
go to jamaica and write for a couple
weeks and run on the beach and do that
kind of stuff and
i was just not at that i wasn't
at the point mentally or spiritually i
felt like that
i would be getting anything good out of
it did something happen in particular
that made you go
now i'm ready um
it's just time it was just time you know
it was just time to do it
it had been i'd written some really good
songs and i had once on that i thought
was great
i recorded it like five times and it
just didn't happen and
i just put it down i said okay that's
not gonna work and
and then went on with some other stuff
and and i think it's just when you get a
good song
okay this builds on the next one yeah
and that builds on the next one and then
you have
kind of a amount of
what was the first song that got written
from this new album
i think it was justice i'd written that
a while ago but i hadn't recorded it and
i recorded that
and um hours on end and i'd written duck
confit a long time ago
so i just is that more of a poem or is
that
it's a poem like a spoken word poem yeah
and i just felt it was so
kind of cinematic that it
should be the first song on the record
and
but it was a poem and i got a poem a
little small
chat book that i'm going to put out next
year i was going to ask that
you having recited poems as a child
writing poems as a teenager
then writing music where is your poem
book
yeah well it's coming out i had a book
come out
it was called poems poems poems not
poems not
spelled correctly but i wrote about
three or four of them
and stapled them together with the cover
page it was
you know staple in the top left corner
poems
poems was written really big on the
front spelled wrong every time
and i went and sold them in the
neighborhood for a dollar that's awesome
my mom still has it i think
i saw a picture of it i was like
probably not going to make it onto a
citizen cope album
those things are probably worth a
fortune right now
well maybe when i'm dead art tends to be
worth even more when you're dead
exactly isn't that a shame yeah it is i
really feel bad for artists i think that
it's
not as bad for a musician although of
course i'm sure michael jackson's
um uh
originals and everyone who is someone
you know
an artist when they pass away something
changes yes
because you can't make more yeah but
like you know
i don't know is the paint and things
that make sculptures
musicians get to at least reap some of
the benefits of some
i think who was it that was just
completely pretty much unknown
was it it wasn't monet was it
he's pretty well known no before he died
oh that wasn't well known but until he
died and then his art took off
after he died yeah i don't know maybe
i'm not sure or i don't know was van
gogh
vanco it was van gogh and uh
yeah he probably did have to die for his
artwork to be really popular because he
died of syphilis right because he
literally went crazy
yeah he cut his ear off
oh god that sounds bad go to the doctor
everybody
yes i don't think they had penicillin
back then though
[Music]
cured by penicillin i'm not really sure
i also wasn't sure why you knew
because i had i one time i did get uh
what's it called not syphilis but like
something down there where it was
gonorrhea
it was burning when i was god
way way back before my music days and i
had to go to get the doctor to
penicillin
you know what modern medicine is like
i'm talking too much
modern medicine is really good for uh
immediate traumas right i don't believe
in modern medicine other than when you
need it that moment like penicillin
because it burns when you pee
and you need medicine but the rest of it
should come through food
yeah food is medicine and let that
medicine be that food exactly
amen so the album is called uh
heroine and helicopters and um
that's obviously an interesting title
yeah
because you haven't done heroin right
nope that got
i got that title from carlos santana the
first time i met him he came back
did you meet him way back in the day
when you're on your first record label
you said yeah
first my first no after that
my first record out that has drama kick
on it yeah and
he he came backstage and
and as you know we introduced yeah and
all that and he says whatever you do
stay away from
the two h's and i'm thinking you know
[ __ ]
no yeah right what i think of a lot of
things
and um he said heroin and helicopters
wait horses are the w nobody judged me
for that
hoses with the h thank you we're really
going good places now
we can't tell if our vibe is higher or
lower but it's fun
it's going down a little bit gonorrhea
so he said stay away from heroin and
helicopter
yeah and so
have you yes i stayed away from i was
always scared of
any kind of needles and all that kind of
stuff so
um i
but i did take a helicopter recently to
a private event
and i was i was like no i don't want to
do this but i i
had to do it too like turns out i can't
levitate yet yeah i'm going to have to
do this
how long was the helicopter ride it
wasn't that long it was
it was from kingston to port antonio and
jamaica
is that an island or is it just another
place on the island it's
it's just another place and kingston it
was like a four or five hour drive
and we had to get there in like an hour
for this rehearsal on the show
so he just it took like 25 minutes
to fly in the helicopter it was good
like
a former guy from jamaica military
jerovus and
it was it was you were safe it was safe
you know what i always tell people the
pilot doesn't want to die any more than
we do no
so just chill out like yeah yeah
it'd be good if he's good at his job and
all but he didn't want to die either
and i think the thing with helicopters
though which even scared me more
somebody told me in hawaii one time was
that it's always a technical
malfunction normally that
makes them crash can't do anything about
that yeah
so um so is there a certain
feel or vibe you said you start with a
song and then it kind of goes from there
is there sort of a a message
a call to consciousness with this record
that is
um meaningful or significant
in the record uh i just
i think i just try to keep it
true to my heart and at the end of it
and if i don't feel
any thorns or in the bushes or whatever
i feel it to be
good and and and true and authentic then
that that's where it leads but i didn't
um necessarily have you know a theme
it's just usually a kind of a pulse of
where the country is and where the my
life is and
where my personal growth is but i think
any music is
and anything i've done in this and i've
found recently
has just been about and i used to think
it was about other things but i think
it's just about
personal growth in general you know
and whatever
whatever whatever can
gets in your way and everything is is
doesn't really matter i think it's all
about
the growth you can make as a as a human
being because
there's you know there's times when i
thought oh man i
it'll it'll make make me enough money so
i can stop selling tickets or i can you
know
little things like that or um i can meet
some pretty women
or whatever it is you know it's just
i think all the things over the years
have just been
really to kind of spiritually grow
did you grow from this record yeah every
time we
do something i every time i play a show
i still learn something really
yeah will you play a little show for me
yeah i'll play a show for you
okay wait first first i want to ask the
one
the one the one question that came from
aaron which is
if i know that i know that songs
it's important for them to mean
something to mean something to you
whatever that may be and that's okay it
doesn't have to be whatever
yeah whatever the writer wrote or was
feeling but
is there some kind of a story to let the
drummer kick
there's a couple stories to it i've
written all the song
all right my old apartment my old studio
and played the piano and the drum drum i
had a drum machine
and um
just played the parts and i'm not a
great piano player
or any of that but it's very basic
and uh did the chorus and i hadn't
finished it and
i was trying to finish it for a long
time but
i guess the meaning of it was a guy next
door to me
and his name was mr copeland which is
ironic
yeah and he was living in the same
building and he used to always say
clarence whatever you do don't give up
and so i said that at the beginning
of of let the drama kick it whatever you
do
don't give up and i think that gives it
kind of a
uh a vibe of of
of of that i think that song embodies
that
and um that was a big hit
will you play it drama play it let the
drummer kick
[Music]
the church wasn't honest to stay with
the youth and
honestly creating hostility among us
teachers said no college still kid
gotta get a check with a couple comments
[Music]
what you've done here is put yourself
between
a bullet and a target and it won't be
long before thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today i hope you enjoyed it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click on the
subscribe button